From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
The Library of Congress
receives hundreds of thousands
of questions each year from
curious minds around the world.
Reference librarians
and subject specialists
from across the Library
are ready and waiting
to help you find the
information you need.
This video will show
you the easiest way
to ask us a question,
through our online Ask a
Librarian service.
This FREE service is
available to anyone, anywhere.
Let's begin on the Library
homepage, at LOC.GOV Go
to the upper left
corner of the page
and click the three
horizontal bars.
From the dropdown menu, select
the Ask a Librarian Link.
This is the Ask a
Librarian Homepage.
Let's get started by selecting
the "online form" located
at the top of the page.
Here we are in the Ask
a Librarian General
Inquiries form.
Sending us a question is as easy
as typing your question
in the box.
I'll try: Is it true
Susan B. Anthony was known
for her red shawl?
I haven't been able to find
any information on this.
Complete the form by
entering your question,
and any additional details,
such as where you've already
looked for information.
Once you have filled
in the required fields,
indicated by a red asterisk,
click "Ask Your Question"
to finish.
A confirmation page will appear
to indicate your
submission was successful.
You will also get an
e-mail confirmation.
A librarian will send a
full response generally
within five business
days or less.
If you have a specific reading
room you would like to consult,
you can choose it from the list
on the Ask a Librarian homepage.
For example, if you
had a question
about civil war era
photographs, you may wish
to route your question to the
Prints and Photographs Division.
If you are not quite sure which
link to choose, don't worry.
Go ahead and select the
"online form" located
at the top of the page.
No matter what, Librarians
will direct your question
where it needs to go.
In addition to the Ask a
Librarian online request form,
some areas of the library offer
chat during limited hours,
indicated by the chat icon.
Whatever your question, our
reference librarians are ready
and waiting to provide you
with the information you need,
so go ahead and Ask a Librarian!
This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us as LOC.GOV,